With coming to the final section of the sound,
the fury.
And I think that,
um,
a question that we'll have to arise for everyone,
uh,
is why isn't catty the person to be telling the story in session four?
It seems kind of logical,
right?
You know,
each of the four brothers,
it'll have three brothers,
um,
get the guest to tell a story in one session.
So it would seem logical that Kelly should be the narrator in session four.
Um,
this is not a choice.
They thought the mix.
So we have to think about why he decides,
again,
using catty as the narrator.
Um,
so again,
just say that to us it might seem as if it would be good to have a woman's
voice,
uh,
in that last section.
Uh,
it is the missing point of view has been missing so far how it feels to be a
caddy,
uh,
if suddenly we have restore a more balanced gender dynamics to the sound of the
fury.
So,
um,
I think that those are the,
uh,
the,
the reasons that one would argue for having catty,
uh,
as the narrator.
And I would encourage you to think about that in your section,
you know,
to have a discussion on this point,
whether you would prefer to have as and area,
uh,
but today in today's lecture,
um,
I like to explore falconers reasons for deciding against having Kelly as a
narrator.
Um,
and the choice that he does make,
uh,
which is,
to have not a first person singular and not an I tell him the story in section
four,
but instead to have ignition duration,
um,
tow from an outside point of view.
Um,
and I would argue that this narrative choice on Faulkner's pot is also maps onto
a thematic emphasis on a collectivity,
on a communal voice.
So it was not one person's point of view,
but is that a really a group of people,
um,
the interrelations,
and what emerges from that collectivity.
And,
um,
in thinking about these questions I think is useful to go back a little bit to
the publication history of the sound and the fury.
Um,
as you guys know,
the first edition came out in 1929 in San Diego.
The crash as we saw last time.
Um,
and um,
in 1946 random house decided to bring out the portable Fortner additive by a
very important,
uh,
Arthur and critic,
Malcolm Collie.
Um,
and so who,
who's also a big fan of farmers.
So Malcolm colleague was just editing.
There's [inaudible] which in turn out to be a very successful edition.
It was used a lot.
Um,
and um,
this is the 1946 edition of the Political Falkland Really Analysis the
importance of partner.
Uh,
he,
he's,
uh,
the kind of author about home,
you will have a portable something edition.
Uh,
so,
um,
it was a great thing for Faulkner.
And in preparation for the portable Faulkner,
um,
he decided to write an appendix,
to sound and the fury to be included in the portable partner.
And this is what he said to Malcolm Collie,
uh,
before it came out October,
1945 about the appendix.
I should have done this when I wrote the book than the whole thing with our
fallen into pattern,
like a jigsaw puzzle when the magician's one touched it.
So that's the degree of attachment of importance that he would attach to the
appendix.
Um,
although since he was writing in 1945,
almost 20 years after the original sound of the fury,
um,
he had a somewhat change,
idea about the novel.
Um,
his regulation of the novel seem a bit skewed even to mark and Carly.
So Carly real bad him and if it meets their axes of the original sound of fury,
just remind him what was in the original novel,
um,
and asked if he would consider,
changing the,
revising the appendix a little bit in light of what he actually written and
designed a period but farm that when there any of that he was stick to as
appendix.
And not only that,
the same year random house decided to bring out and do addition of the sound of
fury.
And as I lay down,
we'll be reading as I lay down a little bit later on in 1946,
those two were brought out,
you know,
the saying go do addition,
um,
under the modern library imprint,
which is a cheaper paperback edition of Random House books.
So it came out in the modern library edition.
And in preparation for that father was also very emphatic that the appendix
should be in there.
So this is what he wrote to Robert [inaudible],
senior editor at Random House,
um,
at the beginning of [inaudible] 46.
When you read it,
the appendix,
you will see how it is the key to the whole book.
And after reading it,
the four sections as they stand now foreign into clarity and place when you
issue in the book,
friend is appendix first and title it appendix then continue with the sections
as they now are,
be sure and print the appendix first.
So far we're really has very strange ideas about him,
more than of the appendix.
That's theme,
a little dubious.
Even two is devoted fan Malcolm.
Um,
and the appendix worsening in fact included in the 1946,
um,
modern library addition,
and it was included,
um,
in many additions of the sound of the fury,
all through the fifties,
sixties,
seventies and the 80s are editor started checking it out.
And so in our edition,
as you can see,
there's no appendix,
um,
in our edition of the vintage addition,
which was also published by random house.
Uh,
but,
uh,
just for your reference,
I will,
uh,
post the appendix onto our website.
Some of you will see it for yourself,
um,
if,
whether Faulkner's a point,
whether it is in fact the key to the sound and fury.
But once again,
remember the loss of people actually had reservations about the appendix.
So don't think that it is in fact the key to the novel.
Uh,
but the appendix does.
Um,
tell us quite a bit about how Foglar um,
things that are catty and how you,
things the other wrestlers are novel.
So this is his very,
very long entry on caddy Candace caddy dude.
And knew it extended to do without either seeking of fleeing loved her brother,
this bite him,
loved him not only in spite of,
but because of the fact that he must value about,
or not her,
but the virginity of which she was custodian and on which she plays no value,
whatever new,
the rather love death.
Best of all,
I was not jealous.
[inaudible]
in Paris,
the German occupation,
19th for the,
um,
for a good part of that entry on Kelly.
It is a very,
very good summary of her plays in the sound of fury.
And you can see why Faulkner,
we're not one her,
uh,
to tell the story on that.
Uh,
her importance in the novel is her importance to her brothers.
Um,
and the way in which,
uh,
she is really not important.
She's an ideal of virginity issue.
There an arbitrary of virginity that is so important both to Benji and two
Clemson.
Um,
and so she was really a kind of a cipher for her brothers.
and that's why she is what she is always existing in the minds of brothers,
but never having an independent existence of Hurrah.
But this one other weird thing that comes out of the appendix which comes out in
this little detail and far from the go on to elaborate on that,
um,
fell further,
creates a whole other story about a county,
uh,
the show and to Paris,
that she was there apparently when the Germans occupied Paris.
Um,
and then there was this other detail about a picture of her falling into the
hands of the library in Jefferson,
a woman who look like caddy,
who was hanging out with a German Nazi officer.
And then the librarian wasn't sure that was catty,
but she showed a picture to Jason just showed into the doc.
And nobody knew whether or not that woman who was hanging out with Nazi officer,
whether that was caddy.
So a whole new industry on photos in the course of the appendix.
And clearly Faulkner,
maybe it was even thinking of another novel based on Carrie,
uh,
you know,
his,
his way of writing a new novel back into the sound.
You can see that she would not be the appropriate person to be telling the story
in session four.
So we'll see what father Ashley ends up with,
what he chooses a two as his,
um,
you know,
uh,
kind of a representative,
um,
in,
in session for the most authoritative,
um,
where you're telling the story,
which was actually through a third party for this own nation duration.
Um,
and,
um,
that is linked to some degree with his understanding of what section four is
about.
Um,
and that is the,
the two people that he mentioned at the end of the appendix and that was all the
others were not comms and they were black luster man,
age 14,
who was not only capable of the complete care and security of an idiot twice as
age in three times his size because keep him entertained
deucey day and do it.
So these are the two people that he would like to talk about in those other
sensors,
um,
in session four.
And I actually agree with that.
That makes a lot of sense.
They have been so important all through the novel.
And finally in session four is devoted to luster and a,
um,
and all that revolves around them in the future that emerges from this focus on
luster.
And they'll say,
uh,
we already have seen something about last year that he is very young but he's
capable of replacing catty and taking good care of Benji.
Uh,
well there's odd about this.
Three words used to describe those.
There is still say day and doing.
So Pharma is super conscious of pronouns and he's afraid og way of not the use
of non what appears to be a non matching pronoun.
It should've been daisy.
She and doers in say interviews is the third person thorough.
And I would argue that session four is inside of session dominated by their
pronouns.
That is involved in this very peculiar fashion.
Is the session devoted to the bird person thorough by way of someone?
Like they'll say,
um,
so less in the resume,
the lecture,
I'll be thinking about session four along those lines.
Um,
we know there's really,
this is the first thing that we know.
There's this omission [inaudible].
Um,
and these are the other points that would like to make about the whole thing
through her.
We see the legacy of slavery.
Um,
we see a shift between outside,
inside of nation and duration is an external point of view,
but quite often there's a shift back to the interior of the Osi,
uh,
and along with our chef,
um,
a kind of tension between say the sandwich between the visual and the auditory
registers.
Um,
with,
because it's a question of endurance day and do,
um,
farmers thinking about the future of race and of the United States by way of
race and the tomorrow of race.
Um,
and,
um,
we'll test a concept that we used last time that we took from Raymond Williams,
the knowable community as well as whether or not that could be resurrected,
um,
in section four.
And the question who wrestle ration comes out because session or is Easter
Sunday is the day on which song resurrected in the textbook itself.
Falconers using that as the frame for the idea of resurrecting something else.
And,
um,
obviously we think because Benji's and they're still everyone else,
Jason is still there.
Uh,
there's the possibility for cross racial,
we emerging from day and do,
um,
and as promised last time,
the horse Quinny actually mixed an appearance as well,
um,
in session for the sound and fury.
In fact,
she is very,
very important.
Um,
so we'll think about,
uh,
we're not quite at the place where we can talk about a community made up of
humans and nonhumans.
Uh,
but it is interesting.
That is not,
uh,
the automobile,
but it comes back in a big way at the very end of the sound of the fury.
So,
um,
let's start out with ignition in the region.
Um,
and I think that there's a temptation on our part to think that on the ocean
duration is going to be benign.
That okay,
section one is told by Benji who was mentally retarded.
Section two is told by a Quentin who's going to kill himself.
A session three is taught by Jason,
totally obnoxious but very sad,
very pathetic character.
Um,
session certain is Tobais and definition narrator or so we might assume that
this is going to be benign,
that this is going to be full of goodwill.
That is not necessarily the case.
Um,
and in fact,
the ignition erasion actually begins with a fairly of putting external,
uh,
and objectifying view of dose it in the sense that she's turned into an inert
object to be observed.
So it's very striking and to some extent,
puzzling narrative choice on [inaudible] part.
This is the morning of Easter Sunday DLC opened the door of the cabin and emerge
needled laterally into her flesh precipitating NASA,
much the moisture as a substance partaking of the quality of thin,
not quite congealed oil to all us.
The Velvet Cape with the border of mangy and anonymous for about the address of
purple silk.
And she stood in the door for a while with a myriad and sunken face lifted to
the weather in one call and hand flags sold as the belly of a fish.
It's a repost a picture of they'll say,
uh,
and it is first of all observing her as very,
very close range.
This has really deal say captured on not even the micro register but almost like
a nano,
uh,
register,
um,
in a sense that we're not even seeing her eyes were not seeing her hair or um,
you know,
the smart possible a smile and nod and smile on her face.
Um,
we're looking at something that maybe is sweat coming out for,
but it is not moisture.
It is a layer,
a thin layer of congealed of oil.
They're sticking to the skin.
Um,
it completely physical mechanical description of doc at very close range.
It's almost Wagner telling us that when it comes to the ignition,
Eurasia is as good as the next guy.
Didn't give us the most minute details,
most of mine you impersonal,
um,
and non benign,
level of detail attached to [inaudible].
Um,
from that very minute and non benign in the sense that is in is completely
neutral description of days and we move on to a slightly larger scale.
Um,
and now we know there's the clothes that she's wearing.
and she's wearing fancy clothes.
She's wearing clothes to goodwill station,
she's wearing a velvet cape and a silk dress.
So we know that those are not really her clothes.
Right?
Those are the hand me downs,
um,
scar there by her mistress,
Mrs Compson and she's wearing them with uh,
so right there we have the legacy of slavery and coded into articles of clothing
that are to be farmed on doc.
And I would emphasize that they are to be found on say in the sense of there's
not a whole lot of Asian say in dosage choosing to wear those clothes.
They are just handling me.
I given to her.
So flavoring is also something that was historically a given and quite possibly
is still a given in the 20th century.
Uh,
the blood,
the African American characters in session four are not slaves anymore.
This is the 20th century.
Slavery was a thing in the past,
but there is still the legacy of slavery.
The shadow of slavery hanging over everyone's head asked,
they will see is still wearing the old clothes of her mistress.
Um,
so in that sense,
in thinking about the legacy of slavery,
the sound of fury could be staying in the company of other,
uh,
other narratives are not novels,
but narrative,
um,
that were emerging or being produced in the 1930s just a little later.
Um,
and this was the project sponsored by the Federal Writer's project are lots of,
um,
during the great depression when loss of unemployed,
authors,
we're going around the country under the sponsorship of the federal government
to talk to add slaves,
um,
and to get the live stories,
and to make sure that those are on record and archive.
Um,
so there's that desire in the 30th to capture something that will vanish
otherwise Spanish forever.
Um,
and,
uh,
those are really interesting archives to look at.
Um,
you know,
if you ever decide to go the graduate school,
um,
in their Azure and decide to do something on Faulkner,
it would be very interesting to look a dose in conjunction with what Fox News
says about the slaves and the sound of the fury.
Uh,
but that's just the kind of a reference point that what else is happening.
Um,
within the sound of the fury,
we see that the legacy of slavery,
it's basically a kind of a hostility,
a visual hostility directed against a doc.
And she's an enormously,
enormously sympathetic character,
but she's not completely in the year from a hostile gaze that is a part of the
omniscient narration.
Omniscient narration is completely neutral.
Um,
it doesn't side with anyone.
It can be both for someone or get someone and initially used my fault actually
is used against,
they'll say,
but as is the custom with Faulkner,
quite often,
uh,
you know,
we see that he gets,
this is giving us to both sides of the picture.
Um,
that neutral,
maybe even hostile view of doc is quickly modified and is mollify when some
enters the picture.
So we're getting pretty much the same dynamics that we've seen in Fitzgerald.
The interplay of sight and sound,
auditory and the visual registers,
um,
almost always produces a change in the visual field.
Um,
and this is what happened this to doc and it happens in one significant setting.
The kitchen they will say is preparing breakfast.
They'll say,
prepare to make biscuit as she ran the sifter Steli about the breadboard.
She's saying to herself at first,
something without particular tune awards,
repetitive more info and plaintive Astir as you gran theend steadies knowing of
flour onto the breadboard to still have began to hit the road and to fill in
with as miners after fire.
And presently she was singing louder as if a voice to have installed out by the
growing warmth.
So as boys takes over,
the Pronoun also changes a little bit.
We're still sticking with the third person singular pronoun,
but already there's a degree of interiority emerging in this portrait.
It is not just an external view of they'll say,
but the quality of sound that is coming out of her and as the quality of song is
coming out of her,
we see what she's like when she's working,
when she's in a place that she is familiar with this shoes at home.
And Dan really is for domain.
The kitchen is her domain and when doc is in her domain,
she turns into a different kind of person.
Um,
the Sandlers your mates is still attached to the work that she has to do.
So this no cessation of work as she sayings,
but the very rhythm of work and enables those here to turn it into a different
kind of character.
She's very,
very different when she's singing.
Then when she's seen as in a nerd object outside of cabin.
Um,
so,
and one thing that happens,
one other thing that emerges about doc,
um,
in the kitchen,
is there,
she has a relation to time and here I just want to say that,
um,
in session four,
this actually both,
um,
something that emerges about,
they'll say,
but there is also a backward reference to three emblematic moment in visual,
the three preceding section.
So what we'll see in session four,
I think that this is the structure that thought his work working,
um,
really very intricate and very well crafted structure,
is to give us one moment that,
uh,
is emblematic of Dosa.
Um,
that is,
uh,
response,
rejoinder,
uh,
or an amendment to earlier moment that was problematic in one of the preceding
sections.
So just let's look at this,
um,
very interesting moment.
Um,
very memorable in graphic moment.
although we're sound strong in about,
they'll say,
um,
also in the kitchen on the war about a cupboard in visible safe at night by lamb
light.
And even then it advancing and the nomadic profanity because it had,
but one had a cabinet clock tick then with a preliminary sound as it had clear
the stroke,
stroke five times
evil due season.
Okay.
So cloud,
this thing Australian five doc knows is eight o'clock.
There's not up with five windows.
Just hardworking.
She's not up at 5:00 AM she was [inaudible] she knows that this is eight o'clock
clock.
She knows the coauthor of well.
Okay.
So we are bad to the notion of unknowable community.
In this case.
It is a community betraying.
They'll see and the Clark and significantly it emerges and the course of working
height,
labor,
what hard enough.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it was a war game and isn't a very familiar setting.
This is the most important thing that the kitchen is a familiar setting to those
a,
and the clock is also her birth and million is a mechanical contrivances.
But in a case,
in this case it is the mechanical contrivances that isn't quite working right.
First of all,
the club has really not doing a number of things.
It is invisible in broad daylight.
You can only see it at night by landline.
Even then you can barely see it because it's only has one hand.
So this is not functioning properly,
is also enough function in public.
This is not telling the right time.
Um,
but all of that are only makes the kitchen and more important normal community
is only when you have a detective defective instrument and you know that
instruction your while that you can prove that you actually know this domain
very well.
So,
um,
they will see his knowledge of this place is proven without um,
you know,
with just,
just,
it's beyond doubt that she knows this place very well.
Um,
and um,
this emblematic moment about doc obviously brings back and equally emblematic
moment about Quentin and his relation to his watch,
right?
This is the first thing that we know about Quentin.
So let's look at this opening of his section and his relation to time.
As we've seen,
and especially his relation to his own watches.
When Raj,
when the shadow of the Sash appear on curtains,
it was between seven and eight o'clock and then I was in time again,
I went into the dresser and took up the watch for the face still down.
I'd have the crystal on a corner of the dresser and call it the for friends of
glass in my hand and put them in the ashtray and twisted the hands of,
pulled them in the tray to watch tape on.
So two points or contacts between the doc section and this section eight
o'clock,
same time.
Uh,
except that they have the completely different variation to eight o'clock to the
time.
Those eight o'clock for those is another day.
And we know that there'll be many more either class for her.
For Quentin,
this is the last eight o'clock he would ever experience.
It is the very end of the lines for him.
So rather than their,
that is sales who tells us fully who has a future and who doesn't.
But the other thing is that,
um,
doc is able to make do with a broken clock.
Quentin is the one who has well functioning was the,
he smashes twist off the hands of that watch.
Uh,
and he of course he hurts his hand in the course of smashing that watch.
So right there,
yeah,
there's a capsule summary of his few tile battle with time,
um,
and the way went and gets bloodied on this day.
This is finally the day when,
um,
he um,
lose it,
some kind of virginity loosens that the virginity,
that time it is bloating in his struggle at the time.
Um,
so,
um,
it's a very eloquent,
a rejoinder to that earlier moment,
but also a rewriting of that earlier moment.
It is a dad and for Clinton,
no doubt about it.
There's no way [inaudible] can keep eye,
although I just say actually in terms of thoughtless models,
he actually wrote another novel,
affluent,
resurrecting Quentin,
um,
in that novel or so.
Um,
he actually manages to find a way to bring Quentin back as well by writing
another novel about him.
But within the sound of fear is no way he can bring them back alive.
Um,
and is that the only way he can wrestle rec,
Quentin in some fashion is to resurrect him by the way of DLCs and her ability
to make,
do with time to come to terms of time to come to the toes,
both with a defective presence and in coming to terms of a defective present to
live onto the field show.
Um,
so we can by way of those and we can start thinking about the arm pulling
concept of tomorrow and it has to do with the tomorrow of race.
So we know first of all,
the importance of the kitchen and what takes place in the kitchen.
Um,
we also know in the rest of the section that is another place that is as
important as the occasion.
And that is the black church,
right?
So these are the two emblematic locales where there could be you tomorrow.
Um,
and where there could be an interesting development to that Pronoun.
Third Person Thorough.
Um,
and we'll,
we'll see that in the church.
I'm the central figure in that church is the preacher or the reference shake out
and we'll see what he does.
Um,
and we know that this is Easter Sunday,
so this is the restaurant restoration or something.
And we'll finally talk about the possibility of that Utopian ideal across ratio.
We,
but first of all,
this,
um,
is the church,
the uh,
Christian Methodist Episcopal church in Oxford,
Mississippi.
Um,
and,
uh,
as a historic church.
And,
um,
I want to bring to you attention,
a figure who's written eloquently about the black church and that is,
uh,
someone you might have read in another class.
Um,
W E B Dubois.
he was a very important author.
Uh,
he also,
uh,
as they studied sociology,
so he wrote the book 1903 vogue,
um,
called the Negro church,
basically a sociological report,
a bit based on lots of field work about,
uh,
black churches in the south.
Um,
most of us probably haven't read to need church,
only police only specialists would be reading that book.
But there's another book by Dubois,
um,
that I bet a lot of you have read or heard of the souls of black folk also
coming out in 1903 and because he was doing the sociological fieldwork work in
the same time,
if he was writing this book,
and not surprisingly,
he had a lot to say about the black church as a whole chapter called the phase
of our fathers in which he talks at length about the black church.
And this is what he says,
three things,
Karen,
that any links to the black church back to the religion of the slaves.
So this is another way Englishness the legacy of slavery in the central pality
of the black church.
Three things characterized the religion as a slave,
the preacher,
the music,
and the frenzy.
The preacher is the most unique personality developed by the new grow on the
American soil,
the leader,
a politician and Ra,
a Abbas and intriguer and idealists.
All these hears and error to the center of a group of men.
Now 20 now with thousand in number,
um,
two boys account with the preacher is really interesting because this creature
is both someone who's a conveyor of a form of Christianity or from spirituality.
Um,
but divorce also see is that he is more than that.
He's part of the politician.
Um,
he's um,
an orator,
he has to be very good at what he's doing.
He's a boss to some extent.
So they all taught this other non spiritual dimensions,
um,
attached to the preacher.
Um,
and that is indeed the case,
uh,
because the black church,
even though,
um,
the church like this seems very local because it's part of the Methodist church.
Um,
the local Methodist church,
Ashley been lost to the National Denomination,
right?
Methodist church is a national denomination and quite often preachers would
actually go from one city to another.
Uh,
depression is not always stationed at one place and that turns out to be the
case with the reference got in the of,
this is the background to why this preacher is actually wrong all the way from
[inaudible].
He's not a local preacher.
His broad end fully used to Sunday service,
especially from Saint Louis.
And so there's something,
both are is special,
but potentially alien about him and fog node begins.
Atley.
Uh,
he gives us,
once again is once again,
uh,
to plot a portrait of the reference Shagan um,
to poplar tree that is based on a reversal.
As with they'll say,
uh,
we see an external view of the reference check God,
and then we'll see a much more interior Xeo of the reference shave up.
But this is the external view looking at him strictly from the standpoint of a
small town black church looking at this supposedly very important and visitor
coming from Saint Louis,
the visitor,
it was undersized in a shatty of Parker Code.
He had little Lisen black face,
like a small Asian monkey
with a visitor rose to speak.
He sounded like a white man.
His boys was level and call it side too big for him to have come from him.
And they listen at first through curiosity.
As they worked half to a monkey talking,
they began to watch him as they weren't in there on a tight rope.
Um,
so this is very much an external view of what the reference Shaker and is
another sympathy.
Phew.
Um,
he's someone that the congregation to the black local church was highly
suspicious of.
And in fact they were very disappointed in him that he had come all the way from
Santa Louis in broadly is unexpressed firms in the world.
And it turns out that he's much,
much less impressive looking than the own preacher,
um,
whom they would see every week.
Um,
so it was a terrible as a woman,
uh,
for them to look at this monkey like,
um,
tiny a clownish figure.
Um,
and even when he's trust peaking,
he's still are putting,
they're not warming up to him right away because he sounds like white men.
This is a very peculiar,
um,
detail and thoughtfulness and there's no other way of accounting for it.
Other than that,
he was really thinking of the preacher as two boys were that this is not just a
review.
He's not just a representative or some kind of spirituality,
but then he's also an operator and a politician.
Um,
and speaking like black men is possibly,
um,
a sign that he operates in that mode.
But we get a reversal.
We get a switch to a totally different view of the Reverend Shaker.
And let's just say that this external view of the revenue she got real.
It has to do with looking at him as an inert object,
this impersonal objective gaze directed at him and he,
they looked like a gay if you just look at him as a single individual.
So from that alienating perspective,
we now turn to another look at him,
um,
which is not as a single individual but as a communal for us.
So this is the two pose,
um,
that Faulkner,
tries to negotiate by way of the reference a shaker that he could be looked at
just as a single individual.
This big shot preacher from send the worst Orum keep up.
He feels with the community as a voice speaking for them.
Um,
and he takes on a completely different set of holidays when he's standing that
live fused with the community and the congregation seem to watch with his own
eyes.
One of voice consumed him until he was nothing and they were nothing and there
was not even the voice.
But instead the highest we're speaking to one another in chanting measures
beyond the need for worse.
So then when he came to rest again is to reading desk,
his monkey face lifted and there's cold attitude that of Assouline torture,
the crucifix to transcend into shabbiness and insignificance and men have no
moment long moaning expulsion of Braf roasts from them and the women's and
girl's soprano.
Yes,
Jesus.
Um,
we beginning to figure out why the external of jackify ions you have the black
headers is so the liberally thing meaning is so deliberately hostile to them
because Fargo in fat once to suggest that in most people if you just look at
them,
they're really nothing to write on about and feel very sad looking specimens of
humanity.
But the most important thing is that this,
that looking specimens of humanity can be transformed under the proper
circumstances and listening to the voice,
in this case,
listening to the Voice of the referential Edgar in conjunction with the voice of
the black congregation.
That is one circumstance when we completely forget to in significant fiscal
appearance of this math and we just wages w here becomes nothing.
The congregation becomes nothing.
And that's a good thing.
When they become nothing,
that what really does register is that voice at what that voice is able to do
for the congregation.
So this is no without question at the moment of epiphany and the sound of fury
and it's by way of this initially Julius looking creature,
a creature put on Ashley transcends that and is able in fact to do what it's
supposed to be done,
uh,
on Easter Sunday,
which is to bring about some kind of resurrection.
Um,
so this is,
um,
what,
we're already beginning to see happen.
Uh,
we've already seen low bit of it and they'll say is relation to the clock and
her kitchen.
And now we see something else that also happens in the kitchen.
Um,
and is the other black,
the luster and Benji,
uh,
in the kitchen,
um,
the session for Benji comes back in the big way.
So in many ways this is Benji almost incorporated into the black community.
Um,
we've measured earlier that we look,
uh,
that the way in which he and luster,
constantly on a unit and luster livechat other.
Um,
and here we once again see Benji,
uh,
as lusters significant other and the other way around as well.
Luster of phenom with skill and from now and then his attention.
We're return law enough to enable him to find a spoon and cause Ben to close his
mouth.
Ponding empty air.
But there was a parent in the lusters mind elsewhere,
his other hand lay on the back of the chair and upon that their service it move
tentatively delicately as if he were picking and an audible tune out of the den
Floyd.
And once he even forgot to take spin with a spoon and why his fingers tease out
the disclaimer with the sounders and involve a pair g or until Ben recalled him
by women praying.
Again,
I'm fairly on detail about luster.
Luster doesn't play any musical instrument at law.
Fog node is counter factually representing him as picking and in all of over
two.
And not only is it an olive oil too,
and not only has must have become a decision in this moment,
but his way a special kind of music and of head Yael.
Okay.
So while there's an individual is a special musical technique,
um,
the call not the way not being played in unison,
but the lady in sequence,
usually the court will be played together,
but the patio is one in which you played a court in sequence one at a time.
So another way,
um,
and other,
the English translation for the Italian with a measure is actually a broken
chord.
Um,
and this is actually the kind of music that,
uh,
that,
that lost her place is that slavery and the legacy of slavery is that broken
chord.
The listening,
not the most harmonious kind of music.
Um,
but as we know,
this,
the shoe with actually has a great piece on the [inaudible] only.
So now there was a wonderful piece of music,
um,
and as one of the most famous signature pieces by she would,
but,
um,
this is,
lost days from pipe playing that,
uh,
but here's the pairs you is interesting.
And in that farmers turning this,
uh,
you know,
not very well school black character into a train the session.
So this is the reconstitution of unknowable community based on a special kind of
knowledge.
And we know that luster,
Ashley doesn't know something,
right?
He knows something.
That's why he's cancer minded.
His mind is fixated on something else,
something that only he knows.
So let's go back,
um,
to what it is that lost a knows that makes him so absent minded at this moment.
This is the second,
uh,
reference back to an earlier moment in an earlier section.
This is actually the very ending the veggie section.
So that one,
this restaurant,
that as well,
and the absent mindedness of,
of,
of flustered.
Um,
same configuration luster and then Jay,
he put my Gal on I hush and the luster stop his head too.
What the window that he went to the window and looked out.
He came back and took my arm.
He or she come,
he said,
be quiet now.
We went to the window and looked out.
He came out with his window and climb across into the tree.
We watched the tree shaking,
the shaking when down the tree.
Then he came out and we watched it go across the grass.
Then we couldn't see it.
Benji's totally clueless at this moment.
That's the is really knowledgeable about what exactly is coming out of plantains
window so that when we do find out in session four,
the Quentin has run away there.
She's taken our Doosans money with her initial glance away.
That is all news to those to his known all through the novel starting from
session one,
he already,
that bit of knowledge is in his possession so this is the reconstitution of the
knowable community for luster is that he is familiar.
Quentin is is familiar.
He knows her well enough to know that this is something that she might do.
Um,
and it has bad reconstitution of the knowable community that once again,
Russell,
Greg's this previous moment from Benji and allows her to take on a new life.
So since we're really looking at the structural to wrestle rector earlier
moments in section four of the sound of the fury,
less look at the resurrection of one other thing.
And not surprisingly,
it is the third brother who would get resurrected in that moment.
And this has to do with a landmark and ask her,
which is the courthouse square.
And we know that luster and Benji and habit of going out for a ride with
Queenie,
the horse.
Um,
but in this case,
in,
at the very end of the sound of the fury in something seems to be going wrong.
Um,
luster and Benji go on,
arrived poly every day and nothing especially happened.
Um,
you know,
it was just peaceful,
right?
But on this one occasion,
some things seems to be going wrong and Benji is bellowing without stop on this,
right?
Some things seems to be going wrong.
Luster for all.
His knowledge of what Quentin does is actually incapable of controlling the
situation,
is unable to stop.
Benji from bellowing inadequately takes Jason's intervention to stop the
bellowing of engine.
So let's look at what it is that Jason is able to do with a bad hand tableau
keyhole luster Osi and hold the reins and saw Quinny about and double the reins
back and SculpSure across the hips.
He cover again and again until plunging Gallup while bands course agony wrote
about them and so on her about the rate of the mining and the his struck luster
over the head with this,
please don't you know better than to take him to the left.
He said he reached back and struck Ben Breaking the flower stock again.
Queenie moved again for fear began to club clubs.
They'll only again,
and that one's been hush
last to look quickly back over his shoulder.
Then he drove on the broken flower drooped over Ben's fest and his eyes were
empty and blue and as really,
and again as corners and facade flow smoothly,
once more from left to right person,
tree window and doorway and sideboard each in it's ordered.
So that was what went wrong initially with the rye is that luster for some
reason have forgotten that they're supposed to go to the weight of the
[inaudible],
he makes clinic or to the left.
And so everything is happening in the long order.
And because Benji cannot stand anything happening in the water,
nothing will stand in front of Valerie.
So this is a very interesting moment where from that has granted until last
year,
a lot of knowledge in Noah's Quintlin very well.
But for some reason he doesn't know Benji.
And this one occasion it takes Jason Ashley to demonstrate his knowledge of this
homes rather than,
he doesn't laugh Benji,
but he knows Benji's very well.
He knows that it would have to be to have the weight of the monitor and is able
to correct that mistake.
So after always seeing Jesus terrible parliaments or the automobile at the very
end of the sound of the theory follows evil to resurrect Jason to budge.
Happier faith automobile is gone,
is back to the world of the causes and carriages,
a 19th century world still lingering on.
And to some extent the comedy,
the carbonate,
Jason,
even in the 20th century is not a pretty sight,
is not a nonviolent,
well,
days are still heading.
Last term,
hips,
bricking,
bands,
flour.
So none of the obnoxious things about James has gone away.
He hasn't turned into a sweet person.
He still monster.
But why?
He remains monster of this made his world one that he can listen and that he can
be a herald of sauce in Israeli.
One brief moment,
he can be the person who comes to the rescue and sent everything back onto the
right track.
There are like,
so this is the way in which the [inaudible] off the sound and the fury is in
fact an Easter Sunday story about resurrection.